un señor o petita había presentado su
renuncia la semana pasada porque una
revista francesa había publicado que él
había tenido una relación con una mujer
en el año 2012 recordemos que él es
arzobispo de parís desde el 2017 él en
ese momento renunció confirmó
efectivamente que tuvo una relación
inusual con una mujer dijo que no era ni
sexual ni amorosa lo dijo también a la
arquidiócesis de parís pero que él
renunciaba básicamente para no dividir a
los fieles dijo él pero también ha
habido denuncias en ese mismo artículo
del mal manejo que él hacía de la
arquidiócesis que era muy autoritario
con los curas y también algunos bienes
unos edificios que no habían sido
declarados lo cierto es que lo que llamó
sobretodo la atención de aquí es la
rapidez con que el papá francisco ha
tomado la decisión sobre todo que hoy él
comienza un viaje a chipre pues
recordemos en otros casos por ejemplo
cuando hemos señor barbarán el arzobispo
de lyon a renunció presentó su renuncia
porque era acusado justamente por no
haber denunciado los casos de violencia
sexual de un cura contra los niños
scouts
la papa le rechazó en un primer momento
la renuncia después el volvió a
presentarlo y finalmente la terminó
aceptando pero eso tomo mucho tiempo en
casa en cambio aquí han pasado solamente
algunos días y el papá ya ha aceptado
esta renuncia dice el comunicado de el
vaticano que no se juega con el celibato
así que ya también hay una reemplazante
para él es monseñor georg pont y él es
antiguo arzobispo de marsella en el sur
de francia